With an initial exchange rate of USD 1.1789,
January 1st of 1999 has gone down in history
as the day the euro was born.
It began to operate as an electronic currency,
used in financial markets and for cashless
payments.
However, it wouldn’t be until three years
later, that is the beginning of 2002, when
the Euro coins and notes that we all know
today began to circulate.
It had all started a decade earlier, on January
1st, 1991 when 11 member countries of the
European Union decided to integrate their
local currencies – currencies such as the
mark, franc, lira or peseta – under the
supervising umbrella of the European Central
Bank.
The Euro era had begun.
And it did so in style.
Expectations were huge.
Perhaps no one showed more confidence in this
new currency than the then European Commissioner
for Monetary Affairs, Yves-Thibault.
Since then, 20 years have passed, a time in
which the new European currency has gone through
both good and bad times...
Which means, on many occasions, the euro has
been the main topic of public debate.
Because, folks, we can’t deny it, the news
is notoriously pessimistic.
Catastrophes and bad news draw more attention
than positive events.
It’s easy to believe that the latest news
supercedes any slow and steady trend.
So, in recent years we have been hearing all
kinds of theories about what the euro has
meant and forecasts about this currency’s
future.
Surely, you must’ve heard at some point
that the euro is doomed or that its arrival
has led to winning and losing countries in
the eurozone.
But what’s the truth?
What assessment can we make of the 20 years
that the euro has been part of most Europeans’
daily lives?
What challenges does it face?
Well, to answer these and other questions
and to celebrate the 20th anniversary of the
European currency, thanks to the support and
sponsorship of the European
Central Bank, some of VisualPolitik’s team
members traveled to Frankfurt.
In this video, we’re going to try and find
out what the euro has meant and what challenges
it faces.
So, let’s go.
(UNITY IS STRENGTH)
I think the first question we need to ask
ourselves is quite clear, how and why did
the euro emerge?
To answer this question, we need to go back
to the 80s, a decade that wasn’t particularly
good for Europeans.
At that time, Europe’s economy wasn’t
having a great time.
These were years of stagnation and bad statistics.
For example...
Unemployment in the European Community’s
countries had practically doubled, going from
5.8% in 1980 to over 11% just five years later;
Potential growth had decreased by three points;
Public deficits had begun to emerge with levels
above 3%
And to make matters worse, the United States
had tripled their imports subjected to trade
restrictions.
Well, it was in this context that the idea
of building a true common market that would
allow European nations to boost trade and,
subsequently, strengthen their economic growth.
The idea was to create a market without barriers,
without customs, without tariffs, without
restrictions for all goods.
To do so, all administrative obstacles would
have to be eliminated and the disparity between
rules and regulations ended.
If a product could be sold in one country
of the union, it could be sold in any of them.
But... not only that.
A genuine common market had to work with the
same currency and with the same monetary policy.
Among other things, this would prevent countries
competing with each other by devaluing their
respective currencies over and over again.
And that was quite common in those times.
For example, between 1979 and 1992 alone,
Italy devalued the lira seven times.
In just 13 years, seven devaluations!
And what’s more, setting a common currency
would make trade between the European countries
much, much easier.
Companies would no longer have to look at
exchange rates, monetary policy decisions
from different governments or currency risk
hedges, among many other issues.
And, you know what?
The creation of the single market has been
a clear example of success.
It fulfilled its objective.
Intra-Community exports have moved from representing
13% of the European Union's GDP in 1992 to
more than 20% today.
And the volume of intra-community investments
has also skyrocketed.
And, in all honesty, throughout this entire
process the euro has played a key role.
The euro has now been with us for 20 years.
What conclusion can we make?
Has it been good or bad for Europeans?
Let’s take a look.
Folks, Europe has changed a lot in the last
20 years, in some cases for good and in others...
let’s say not so good.
But at this point, let me ask you a question,
yes, yes, to you.
What do you think?
Has the euro been good or bad for Europe?
Well, folks, with the data at hand, I think
we can say that, in general, its influence
has been very positive.
We’ve already talked about it here on VisualPolitik.
Now, the question is, how positive?
Let's put some numbers on the table
Nowadays, more than 340 million people use
the euro and it has replaced national currencies
in 19 of the 28 states that make up the European
Union.
Since its inception, the euro zone’s GDP
per capita has increased by 52%, going from
about 21,000 to more than 32,000 € and today
the work participation rate is higher in the
euro area than in the United States.
In spite of that, inflation has reached an
average of 1.7%, a rate lower than the ones
recorded in the seventies, eighties or nineties.
In fact, the eurozone’s inflation level
in these twenty years has been lower than
that of the Federal Republic of Germany over
the same period of time.
This might explain the euro’s huge popularity.
Actually only 20% of Europeans are against
it.
According to the latest surveys, three out
of every four European citizens have a good
opinion of the currency and think that it
has been positive.
[And let's not kid ourselves, it isn’t strange
to think so.
I’m sure that if you were offered to have
your savings in euros or pesetas – or in
some currency that exists today and resembles
peseta – you wouldn’t think it twice.]
But hold on a second, because not everything
has been sunshine.
In the last 20 years the euro has also faced
some very hard times.
Between 2008 and 2012 things became very difficult.
The global financial crisis caused a lot of
problems in most Western economies, and true
nightmares in some of the countries using
the euro, such as Greece, Ireland, Italy,
Spain or Portugal.
Clearly, that’s when the idea of the two
Europes emerged.
On the one hand were central and northern
European countries, countries that have generally
high productivity indexes, competitive industries
and relatively responsible leaderships.
And on the other, countries that had historically
attempted to compete by devaluing their currencies.
When this option was ruled out due to the
euro, they had boosted domestic demand through
strong imbalances in their payments balance.
So to understand this better, with funding
from abroad, basically from northern and central
European countries.
Financing that had been largely concentrated
in the real estate sector.
We’re talking about countries where the
local governments didn’t implement any structural
reforms that would allow them to be more competitive,
and whose banks were overloaded with loans
linked to the real estate bubble...
Loans that of course lost a lot of their value
when this bubble burst, which, obviously,
put the banks against the wall.
Greece, Portugal, Spain and Ireland – although
Ireland’s case is a bit different – required
some form of financial assistance.
At that time, the distrust and problems were
so huge, that, as you might have heard, there
was speculation about the possible rupture
of the euro.
Among other things because many European states
had to pay such high risk premiums that their
situation was made completely unsustainable.
They could not finance themselves.
In the end, the member countries of the Eurozone
decided to do everything they could to avoid
that scenario and it was then that European
Central Bank President, Mario Draghi, pronounced
these famous words, on July 26th, 2012:
This meant that the European Central Bank
would adopt extraordinary measures to stabilise
the euro.
It started to give longer term loans to banks
or buy a range of assets from banks including
government bonds and corporate bonds, so that
businesses and people were able to borrow
more and spend less to repay their debts.
This has led to more economic growth.
But, folks, at this point the question we
need to ask ourselves is, is the eurozone
really prepared to face a new crisis?
What could happen in the future if one of
the euro member countries has problems?
Folks, over the last few years a lot of different
mechanisms have emerged and been implemented
to strengthen the euro’s resistance.
And that’s not all, existing institutions
such as The Stability and Growth Pact have
also been reinforced.
They/it requires a 3% limit on public deficit
and 60% on public debt from
member countries.
("Within our mandate, the ECB is ready to
do whatever it takes to preserve the euro.
And believe
me, it will be enough”.
Mario Draghi)
And also
by virtue of the Fiscal Stability Treaty,
almost all European Union countries have included
the requirement of having balanced budgets
throughout the cycle in their national legislation.
[Let's hope they respect their legislation]
The European Central Bank has also increased
its capabilities to deal with emergencies.
In short, as you see a lot of changes have
taken place with the aim of reducing the risk
of crisis and, if necessary, limiting its
impact.
The question is, are these measures enough
or should we continue to move forward, for
example with a fiscal union?
Right there, folks, is one of the great debates
that exist right now in Europe.
But, just a second, crises aren’t the only
challenges facing the European Central Bank
and the euro.
The arrival of cryptocurrency and blockchain
have also raised questions:
Will new financial technologies be able to
change the way money works?
Do they pose a threat to traditional currencies?
And this brings us to another very important
question: What about cybersecurity?
Especially in a digital world.
Folks, Europe is facing a lot of challenges,
some of which we
have
already talked about on this channel.
Challenges such as aging populations, growing
international competition, imbalances in the
public accounts of many of the member countries
or even defining exactly what European model
we all want to follow.
The European Parliament elections will take
place on May 26th.
In one way or another, this is the moment
in which all European citizens will have the
chance to raise our voices and decide what
future we want for Europe or what kind of
union we want.
So...
Now you know.
In the meantime, if you found this video interesting,
give us a hand by liking it.
And once again, many thanks to the European
Central Bank for all their help making this
video.
And as always, thank you
for watching.